Speaker 1: Let's talk about that.
I'm really glad that something I've been saying
for a couple of months now is getting more
attention.
It's not getting more attention from me saying
it ought to be clear.
What I mean is I'm glad other people are coming
to the same conclusion, which is that by all
accounts, Republicans should do very well
in the upcoming midterms.
Now we're under six under nine months away
from the midterms.
One of the best chances at Republicans not
doing well is the explosion of the internal
disagreements and civil war that we're increasingly
seeing within the Republican Party, which
we have been covering.
David Siders and Natalie Allison wrote about
this in a piece for Politico called Trump's
circular firing squad threatens Republican
midterm gains.
And this outlines a lot of what we've been
saying.
And the article says nine months before the
midterms, nearly everything is falling the
Republican Party's way from Joe Biden's dismal
approval ratings to rising gas prices and
a seemingly never ending pandemic.
Yet as the RNC concluded its winter meeting
here on Friday, it was censuring two of its
own representatives, Liz Cheney and Adam Kinzinger,
and decrying the House's Jan. six select committee
for what Ronna McDaniel, the RNC chair, called
the quote persecution of ordinary citizens
who engaged in legitimate political discourse
that had nothing to do with violence at the
Capitol.
In a year in which even many Democrats acknowledge
the Republicans will likely win the House.
And despite Republican lawmakers and strategists
pleading with Republicans to keep their focus
on pocket book issues and on Biden, the RNC
is still recasting the events of January 6th
and chasing down enemies of the defeated former
President Donald Trump.
They go on to say for all the energy he creates
at the party's grassroots, his stranglehold
on the party is emerging as one of the biggest
threats to the Republicans otherwise bright
prospects in November.
He has singled out 10 House Republicans for
extinction.
He's attacking Republican governors backing
primary challengers meddling in Senate races,
where it may lead to the nomination of flawed
candidates ill suited for a general election.
He's fomenting rebellion against the party's
Senate leader, Mitch McConnell, and this week
in Salt Lake City.
It was David Bossie, the former Trump deputy
campaign manager, leading the effort to kick
Cheney and Kinzinger to the curb.
Read the entire article, but it gets to the
really key point, which is a sad point for
us, right?
I care about the left.
The left is really failing right now.
It's just really failing in terms of setting
itself up to do well.
Nine.
Months from now in the midterms, sadly, like
it, it it really pains me to admit this, but
the person best positioned to save the country
from Trumpian insanity is Trump and Trumpists
sabotaging their own midterms.
It's tragically sad that this is the case
for the Democratic Party right now.
But with under nine months to go until the
midterms, I'll take any help I can get.
And so when we see Trump doing this insane
stuff, we see Republicans censuring Adam Kinzinger
and Liz Cheney.
Last week, I told you that George W. Bush,
from another wing of the Republican Party,
has donated the maximum allowed by law to
both Lisa Murkowski and Liz Cheney, to people,
to Republicans that supported the impeachment
of Donald Trump.
I will take all of it because they're all
terrible.
Remember, Liz Cheney is not our friend.
Liz Cheney, when the rubber met the road,
voted with Trump most of the time.
So it's all bad.
We're maybe.
I mean, listen, are we even better off with
a non Trump Republican than a Trump Republican?
If the non Trump Republican is slightly less
crazy but more likely to get their policies
passed?
We're poorly off no matter what.
So I would love to see the Democratic Party
get it together and take advantage of this
situation where, you know, historically looking,
it should not be a great midterm for Democrats,
but maybe it could be.
This is the biggest gift we could imagine.
And so we have to do everything we can to
encourage the Civil War to continue.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram page,
which you can find at David Pakman show.